um did you ever attend uh The Lyricist
Lounge stuff back in the day of course
that's where I got started what was that
like because I I just re I I remember I
bought The Lyricist Lounge
uh double disc that came in the
cardboard sleeve
and then there was the one that had the
uh oh no on it which I think was two or
three but then there was the TV show
which was way ahead of its time right it
was super ahead of its time because I
think about how big while and out is
that was kind of like kind of the first
inclination that but Lyricist Lounge
originally was like was it a monthly
event or how often were they doing
Lyricist lounges in New York it varied
man it could have been every week what
was that like though and like what were
the other MCS that you know you were
brushing shoulders with at Lyricist
Lounge it was full of hungry MCS that
when you showed up you got a rhyme
everybody's rhyming [__] the stage we
could be outside decipher go on all
night outside it goes on in the bathroom
that's where [__] went to really
sharpen their [__] and see what you was
you know I met Danny Castro from The
Lyricist Lounge out of ass cap um event
where they were playing demos and they
played my demo and I remember when one
of my songs came out you know the crowd
went crazy in the [__] listening
party so he approached me to perform
I've never performed on stage ever in my
life wow so when Danny invited me that
was the first show I ever did I went to
a Lyricist Lounge showcase I performed
along with Master fool I know and and
shut it down for my first show ever that
[__] that [__] appeared in like
20 30 magazines the photo that said what
happened that night but I also was a
part of the TV show when we were
recording The Lyricist Lounge album
uh we will get into ciphers even in the
studio attacking each other in rhyme
form and that's how they got the idea
for the TV show because we carried our
conversations that way and it was like
Hey that [__] is genius you know it was
myself uh Wordsworth Wordsworth who's
the Beast yeah uh Al skills was involved
so just the way we were interacting and
they were filming they got the ideas for
the show and then you know the rest was
history yeah that show man I feel like
maybe five seven years too early
because I think like man Lyricist Lounge
would have went crazy in like 2012 or
something 2010 like I just feel like
because I when I because I watched wild
and out and I'm like well now it's
really like a like a like it's really
like a battling show yeah like you know
it's mixed with comedy it's mixed with
like but it's like really like it's kind
of dope because it's kind of the rawest
form of like punch lines The Lyricist
Lounge show was theatrical super
theatrical there was a lot of makeup
involved costumes and that's what I love
hey don't be surprised if you see
another version it was kind of yeah that
lyrics Just Lounge the show for people
never saw it it was kind of like if you
mix Dave Chappelle and wild and out
together yep Chappelle showing while and
out together you know what's crazy um
some of our writers on The Lyricist
Lounge show were actually the writers
from and live in color oh wow that we
had behind the scenes man so and it was
tremendous fun doing that show because
same thing we go [__] film right all
day and then we you know we rented
houses and lived together when we get
back home [__] is going at it
all night rhyming like attacking you
know deciphers so it was a beautiful
time man you were super close with a
juice right I show you ice I just went
to see juice yesterday I didn't even
know he was in Cali what's crazy is when
I first got Napster when the Napster
wave happened so my best friend's
brothers and Dilated Peoples so when I
was a kid I was around them a lot um
like raqqa and evidence and those guys
um but I saw Supernatural open up one of
their shows and it [__] blew my mind
crazy you should ever saw as a 12 year
old kid watching Supernatural spin
around and turning to Busta Rhymes and
take people's IDs and [__] insane but
I remember like one of the first things
I downloaded I downloaded the Big L
Jay-Z seven Minute Freestyle on Napster
and then I downloaded the juice
Supernatural battle whatever one I
downloaded on Napster but then I
discovered juice and I was like damn
this dude is [__] mean like it's
crazy that there's like this pocket of
like MCS that in the grand scheme of
like where we consider like the greatest
right just for whatever reason don't get
their flowers like juice is one of those
guys well those those flowers are coming
man cause
we all United right now true
Supernatural me and um we got a lot of
things planned man so it's like I always
seen MCS like that with those level of
skill sets right as
forever they're the Lifest you know yeah
maybe they don't have the promotions or
the label deals but they skill set you
know keeps them relevant forever like I
just brought supernet out recently
recently to do a show in Orlando Orlando
never seen anything like that if you've
never seen him before and you see him
you're just like never seen anything
like that I'm sure we and that's what I
try to incorporate in like the functions
and the show we bring out not the
popular month the skilled most skilled
[__] you can imagine it could
also just entertain you at a show like
this is true if you are watching
supernet do what he does you are dialed
in live you're just like what is
happening this is insane and it's crazy
because they both my friends right they
both people that I would stay at their
house they would come to my house we
rhyme forever and and then they battle
right so everybody always asks me who's
better who didn't I'm like listen they
both of them are the greatest I've ever
scene you know I mean I think the one I
had it felt like juice won the battle
that I had on CD everybody has a
different um you know perception now
that's what because I didn't download
that battle for juice I just down I just
searched up Supernatural freestyle and
hit download and I was like who's this
other guy this is crazy like well my job
is to have them together so you see how
dangerous they are alone imagine
together
um give me because obviously you were
part of the the rap Olympics right which
were for people who don't know very
pivotal to a lot of people's careers but
I mean specifically we always hear you
know Eminem is synonymous with rap
Olympics and his kind of a part of his
story
um and you were a part of his team when
you did the rap Olympics right
who'd you guys go against was it I mean
I believe it was Project blow out of L.A
uh yep I believe they were the only ones
that showed up there was a long roster
of teams that were supposed to be there
from like every popular rap group that
was out Fuji's was supposed to have a
team they was you know different
representatives for Crews yeah yeah and
nobody showed up everybody on my team
was a master in freestyling off the head
right you know juice Eminem myself
Wordsworth Quest the Mad lad like sit in
the room with us and you will [__]
get blown even Craig G was out there
hanging out with us like staying with us
and things like that so but it was a big
moment man I was gonna say like
for you like
I just remember Eminem being a real
backpack rapper I guess back then if you
knew about him you knew about him but he
was definitively like an underground guy
like he was on sound bombing too he did
the any man record he obviously bad bad
versus evil with him and um and Royce
and he was definitely like
um you know [__] I wouldn't say no
different but like there was guys like
him classified there was guys like in
that kind of like you know the white boy
rapper who could spit like crazy and
then it was just like a switch got
flipped and it's the Dr Dre switch of
course but like
how crazy was that for you to kind of
see appear
just go from like hey I'm battling with
this dude in the cipher and he's doing
the MTV VMAs and he's an absolute
Superstar and it's not like Eminem was
like Eminem was like a lyrical rapper
yeah like he was like
lyrical Miracle spiritual dude so like
you know if you heard his records prior
to him getting a Dre you would never
think like he was even capable of making
crossover records I always believed it
because but his talent levels are so
crazy
is like I knew he was destined I knew
because his talent blew everyone away
you know we had a big mutual respect for
what we both were able to do now
I knew at any moment something was going
to happen and he was really the actual
factual truth you know I always me when
when I credit anyone or anybody in the
industry I base everything off skills
first you know I mean most important
that's how I yeah for me and skills
first right I don't care about nothing
else he had the skills to take it there
you know what I mean so but
you know I was around several artists
and I seen them blow up you know I seen
most in quality I've seen that said you
know as far as my peers are concerned
I've seen them take off I've seen them
take off I've seen so many of us and
then all it did was give me hope and it
showed me that it's possible to see the
level that I am got into I'm like I'm
next I'm coming and even to this day
where I've never I've never had a
situation I've never had a record deal
I've never had any of that but I always
knew that if I stay in it to win it and
I stay consistent my day is gonna
eventually come and that's everybody's
thing as long as you put in the work you
will have eventually reached that
[__] status that way even if I
had to do it myself and which I did but
this is not even the end this I feel
like this is not even the beginning